was there a specific point when you kind
of realized damn this is not what i
envisioned at all and i kind of want out
like was was there a specific moment or
was it just like a build-up of like a
lot of things it was
primarily a build up over a long period
of time it was about four years in uh
when i realized
um that things just weren't looking
right and i still had two years on the
contract left right
and
uh i think one particular thing was like
they hired um
someone that i did not know that they
were going to hire and then all of a
sudden i found out that they were now a
full-time employee in this like really
important position that meant something
to me and i was like wait i didn't
realize that was what was gonna happen
yeah yeah and also there there were
times and i don't know how much i could
say
but i'll see what i can do
they don't exist anymore
true technically uh
there
was
uh a fundraiser that they they put on it
was for a game
and they had just seen the success of
other people who had done fundraisers
for games indiegogo gofundme type things
and they raised like 250 000
for like these games which were like
mobile games but you could play it on
the computer and it was like this really
cool thing with all these inside jokes
from the community right and they said
oh that's cool guys you do that and then
we were like we don't have a concept for
a game they're like ah we'll figure it
out later you just just watch just raise
some money they just made the fundraiser
and then afterwards they were like make
the game and we said we need to have
something to pitch to people you need
and then they're like cool we'll just
tell them the idea then because and then
they're like you come up with the idea
so i came up with the idea ian of course
also we both came up with the idea and
uh
they were like
uh cool you got the idea
let's let's do it i was like we need to
have concept art we need to like show a
build of the game we need to be able to
show what we what we want to do with
this thing they're like ah we don't have
time okay we'll get concept art so all
we were able to do was launch with this
concept art wow and uh
launching a campaign
asking people incentivizing
your fans to give you money well that
did not did not feel right to me but i
felt backed up into a corner yeah and um
you know i think that's probably one of
the things that i regret from my time
there yeah is allowing myself to feel
backed up into a corner yeah to accept
money from people that were excited
about this thing being built of course
you know we did accept money for that
and i did put all of my heart and soul
into making it as good as it possibly
could be still didn't live up to my
expectations and i feel like it was done
the right way it would have but the
the moment that really stood out to me
was there was some
there was some shadiness about um you
know obviously the way they pushed to
earn money for something because they
saw dollar signs right now because
yeah rather than it being like
those types of things if you're gonna
have your audience fund them it should
really be a passion problem yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely exactly and i could
have made a passion project cause i
really was excited about it but it was
so forced and you know rushed
and then um
there was um
uh some some shady stuff about like the
way that
they contributed to certain donations to
make to inflate certain
the way that certain things looked and
that's really all i'll say about that
but it made me feel so weird about it i
was like i need out as soon as possible
yeah right i imagine when they were
doing stuff like that the confidence you
had in the the company was probably a
bit like okay if they're willing to do
this stuff yes not be going so and they
realized that the way that they treated
that was the same way that they were
treating me and all the other people
yeah so a lot of people lost a lot of
money right i mean it was like crazy
what was it i a lot of people lost a lot
of oh yeah yeah eventually look luckily
i i i wouldn't say i foresaw anything
but it didn't feel right and i got out a
year before they ended up closing down
right yeah um and another thing that
that really was a turning point was
uh i i had made a facebook page and it
was i don't know i had like 500 600 000
um followers or whatever you call it
facebook
just like subscribers friends friends
friends
uh and uh yeah it was just it was smosh
anthony and they were like oh this has
smashed the name so this is um
we're gonna run this for you okay i was
like okay yeah yeah sure and then i was
like
hey you know i was kind of trying to
start to silently transition out i think
they kind of picked up on the gist
because we still were contractually
obligated yeah but i was like um can i
can i get my my facebook back they're
like
no it's ours i was like oh
but i i made that thing and you said
that you just wanted to run it because
you were going to help me post content
on there yeah yeah yeah yeah like it has
smosh in the name this is ours
that's [ __ ] up i was like um
jesus okay
and then i i easily settled on that i
was like oh okay okay it's fine it's
just facebook who cares facebook
and then they were like
um they're like okay hey can we get uh
access to your twitter
instagram no no
i
and
and then i immediately i immediately
changed the name from smosh anthony to
anthony padilla
after they asked me for access to that
in a way it's kind of cool that they uh
kind of forced you into being like you
know what [ __ ] this i'm just going to go
on my own yeah [ __ ] brand myself
really it really got me thinking like
could i do something on my own
like outside of this brand that i had
created
yeah and it was really sad because i had
made that brand uh
yeah when i was 14 years old i i made
that as like a little shitty website as
like a forum for me and my my group of
friends at school to to go on and hang
out with each other it was really before
social media it was like we were either
talking on aim or we were going on this
website and uh
yeah it was sad to kind of let that part
of me this like this baby that i had
brought into this world kind of kind of
go yeah god it must be nerve-wracking
trying to do something yourself though
right because like as a as a youtuber
like starting like
ditching your channel which has like
millions and millions of subscribers to
start to start from the ground up again
yeah like i think like you were one of
the first people i know like first big
creators to really like branch off and
try to do something themselves with a
new channel right i did it and it
succeeded and like there wasn't a
precedent set before that really that
you could really succeed by doing
something new right i mean what fred did
that was also another weird experience a
part of me because obviously i mean do
you
it's not a good one
i [ __ ] i shouldn't think i haven't
said it
but it's my heart no no i put my heart
and soul into that movie
oh my god
i feel like it's [ __ ] up
it's it's a part of the way you invite
him onto the show i'll be on here to
talk [ __ ] about my pride and joy listen
i'm gonna i want to talk to
actually did you actually watch that
yeah i loved it
i love i love it in a way as well
yeah it's it's a terrible moment
it's good yeah but it's so fun
amazing part of youtube history where
like everyone had to have a movie yeah
yeah youtube for some reason was like
making [ __ ] movies yeah pop them out
fred had [ __ ] john cena yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
i completely forgot about it
it was just a [ __ ] cool weird time
yeah where people were making movies
whereas like i mean did you even want to
make a movie was it like what was that
like what was going on with that like
because i feel like there must have been
so many people trying to put their
fingers yeah trying to be like no it
should be this it should be this no no
[ __ ] that we should get john cena in it
yeah i don't know it's just yeah oh we
got a song called steve austin oh yeah
from the wwe
well i was like john cena's not happy
it's gonna be stone cold
yeah i want to know about the movie like
what what was all that
yeah uh so we i mean yeah a lot of
people had movies going on a lot of
people were breathing down our necks
saying so when are you gonna make a
movie yeah and
we we did kind of have this dream of
eventually making the movie version of a
smosh sketch yeah yeah yeah and we we
had a lot of uh we nothing concrete but
like ooh what would the movie version of
this yeah
do we get uh if we get a million dollars
do we uh
some we had some of the dumbest ideas of
like where the movie was all
uh smosh sketch uh budget and then we
had millions of dollars worth of money
pumped into the final scene
that was our initial idea no because i
remember on the smosh channel this was
way before the actual movie came out
yeah you guys released an april fool's
video yeah called smosh the movie yeah
we did where it was have you seen this
video i think i've watched this this was
like the last time like april fool's
like youtube video that i saw but it was
like the first five minutes was like the
most insane quality like oh my god this
looks like a movie yeah and then the
remaining hour and a half was you and
ian walking back home
with no
this is cuts
greatest thing ever so then when i heard
that you guys were actually making a
movie yeah i was like yeah say psych
it's just another april fools story for
youtuber movies it was the what was the
name of the one with the ghost
ghost mates ghost mates that was one of
the better better youtuber movies i will
say that one was that was that one we
had a little bit more freedom with and
uh in a weird way though we we almost
stripped out a lot of like what made
splash smosh right with that movie so it
felt weird because it like wasn't quite
um you know a good movie and then it
wasn't quite uh
you know bad youtube movie which is also
entertaining for itself
because you and ian are i think
naturally very good on on camera like
compared to like how some other people
transitioned to the movies kind of thing
i think you and ian did that a lot
better i think it definitely helped that
you guys were already acting in your
sketches yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of
that going on acting
acting in your sketches
i i heard a lot about how uh i should
improve my acting uh in the comments but
uh really oh yeah because they're gonna
go into it they're gonna be like you're
a youtuber you can't act yeah yeah yeah
yeah even if you did an amazing job
[Applause]
yeah but with the movies you know with
the first one it was a lot of um you
know we did have the stream to do it but
then other people you know it was at
defy they they were like um we need to
make this happen and we need to make it
happen in four months uh four months
okay i'm just throwing a random number
of times it could have been six it could
have been eight but i think it was
somewhere probably around six months
jesus and we were like um actually no i
remember it was after we got to a point
in the script writing process that they
said this needs to happen in this very
short amount of time we're like we're
not ready we were we're still like
fleshing this thing out yeah
and uh
it was a thing where we still wanted to
make our videos on youtube we didn't
want to give that up because we felt
like we would have had to drop that in
order to put all of our effort into
making a movie yeah and they were like
don't worry we could hire this person
and they gave us a few options they
hired a person the script was not
anything like i would have wanted it
it was a lot of like is that one on
fiverr
we found a guy
it was a lot of like here's what someone
who
isn't in the youtube space thinks our
videos and thinks youtube is was there
someone who like worked in like you know
hollywood hollywood movies
it was like a hollywood uh script writer
who who did like tv series and i think
some movies as well right and he did do
some funny stuff but um it was very much
like an out-of-touch perspective yeah
and i was like i mean a lot of smart
stuff was cringy in its own right but
yeah like i was cringing at you yeah at
how out of touch these things were i
could not do these things there was this
like area where like memes go to die
that he that that was written where it
was like a space
uh was that in the no no no no wait [ __ ]
that was it [ __ ] i don't think this
john's so familiar yeah you know i think
that ian might have talked about it on a
separate thing okay that's pretty long
this sounds so familiar or maybe we he
and i both talked about at some point
but there was this part written where
was like where memes go to die and it
was he was like
uh he was like taizhonde is in there and
i was like okay first of all you're
trying to make us say that these people
are dead
this sounds so that's kind of [ __ ] up
and then also you are saying
here's all these things that are not
in the now like we're it's just this
weird period piece that just feels too
soon to be a period piece you know what
i mean it might age poorly yeah
it also just sounds like a hello fellow
children moment right yeah yeah
yes i know memes yeah i don't mean
culture yeah yeah these are dandruff
exactly hillary clinton am i right yeah
it felt a lot like that and then we we
did a lot of rewrites and it was still a
very bad movie
a little too hard
how self-aware were you or like on set
to be like guys are we are we making
like i think i was half self-aware right
right i wasn't fully self-aware part of
me
thought
like after a certain scene happened i
was like oh that might actually be good
part of me did think it might actually
be a good movie depending on the way it
was cut depending on the way the special
effects look yeah uh but the way that it
came together was very much i was like
after i was i was we were seeing like
final cuts of it i was like
okay
that's the movie well i mean at least
it's not as bad as shane dawson's movie
that was yeah i mean it depends who you
ask because no that one was really
really bad was it
i i did but i saw it like on the
premiere night where there was so much
hype in the room from all the friends
and family that it was hard to tell yeah
yeah is this a funny joke or am i just
not in a good head space right now
you should go re-watch it sometime
maybe i will yeah that's interesting
okay okay i never even tried that no no
no
okay okay well it was a lot of fun
though and i i think there's some
elements from the you know from the
smosh sketches retained
their
smoshiness yeah it's much easier for me
to sit here and be like you made a
[ __ ] movie
like i could do anything yeah yeah yeah
like my movie would be good
oh you gotta make it in six what
i couldn't even spell
it was a weird process because
you know we had trailers and yeah
we you know we had an acting coach and
we had the pressure of like this is the
movie uh it was something like a million
dollar budget so i was like you got like
the full hollywood it was the full
hollywood experience
and uh you know we had like a writer
there on set to like do rewrites in the
moment if we needed to rewrite something
for time and like there were a lot of
scenes that we had to cut for time and
like they were rewritten on them it was
such a different experience where it was
not
like i could still go to the director
who was alex winter and he's amazing you
know yeah um is he the bill i forget
he's the bill or ted from bill and ted's
excellent adventure the knock kiana
you know oh he's the ted i think
no bill i don't know
the one that's knocking on me yeah yeah
yeah but but alex winter is amazing and
you know his his kids were huge fans of
smosh so he really did want to give it
that genuine smosh view not sure matt's
calling it bad
no matter how much heart and passion
you put into something if there are a
few elements that are slightly off it's
going to all fuel it's going to kind of
all get brought down to that level i
feel like that's what happened there
were a lot of great things that could
have been but then it was like there
were certain elements that just kind of
brought it all down oh we got to cut the
scene because of time that doesn't make
you probably feel very confident you're
like that's not good yeah yeah yeah but
but you know a lot of times we're like
we're going to cut this scene for time
and we end up having this other scene
that totally actually worked fine
without it it was like the rewrites were
okay yeah um they were your like
sketches before scripted so you already
already had were used like memorizing
lines or were you like mostly improvised
before yeah yeah they they were
definitely scripted uh okay but usually
we would like get a take that we like
and then we'd be like go off book for
the final right
half the time we'd go with the off book
version right um but it was a little bit
different so smosh videos we would shoot
uh you know 10 second clips of like this
thing okay you say this thing okay you
say this thing and uh you know when we
do when you do a movie they they really
want you to get like the full scene with
this angle than the full scene the next
angle no jump cuts no no [ __ ] jump
cuts
continuity yeah so a lot of the
acting in it was actually me trying to
remember my lines
if i watch it i'm just like i'm just
trying to remember my lines right now
most of these lines like it didn't
really get past that and also
i got in my head a lot about like
i don't think this is to be the movie
that i yeah yeah that i wish that could
be yeah it would be so hard to like
really turn up and give it your all when
yeah it just doesn't feel like it's
going right it was hard it was like
after the first day even though there
were so many people that had a lot of
passion and
good intentions and a lot of people that
did put their heart and soul into it i
after the first day i was like
this doesn't feel like it's gonna be
what i thought it would be and then it
was it was hard to get out of my head
and get out of that headphones and i
guess you couldn't exactly go to define
be like hey
[Applause]
yeah
it's like the sketch kind of isn't
working let's let's scrap and go to a
new youtuber
let's do a new video you know yeah yeah
well even even down to the sketches it
was hard to say this video didn't work
oh really because there was a lot of
money that was invested into it yeah and
we were given a certain budget each
month right and uh if we scrapped it it
would be like this is cutting into our
overall budget let's just try to make
this work
so when that pressure starts building up
and you have all these other eyes and
voices and
budgets and restrictions
that's when i think things start to kind
of go south in those situations right
and that's when i started to feel like
things weren't really
right even though like i could totally
see why you can't reshoot a sketch after
you shoot it
obviously it makes sense yeah yeah but i
think if i was fully independent there
were a lot of things that i might have
considered yeah reshooting but but
when we have this uh level where we want
the production value to be there and we
kind of reach that point it felt weird
to go back i now know that you could go
back and it's fine but
back then you're like holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah would you ever want to
make another movie with the correct
amount of time and creative freedom oh
man anthony padilla the movie
this is you it's just
i don't know i don't have any any drive
for that i i have been pushing myself
more with
uh the intros of my videos on
my channel that i do now it is scripted
and i realize that a lot of the the
passion that goes into me writing the
words makes it on the camera when i'm
recording this intro that's cool so now
i'm trying to
in a sense maybe i'm like reverse
engineering a way for me to learn how to
acting is by just actually giving the
emotions that i when i write these
things actually the emotions i'm like oh
when you're when you say a line you're
supposed to visualize it
you're not you're not just saying it you
don't just say the word yeah
oh that's what acting is so in a weird
backward sense i feel like i am pushing
myself to learn how to act a little bit
right maybe you know it depends it
depends but yeah right now no
no no no no you've kind of done so much
in the time that you've been on youtube
like is there anything you haven't done
that you want to do eventually down the
line
because i feel like when you just think
about like even just smosh stuff it's
like you guys have literally been at the
top you've done everything you've done
all the big stuff twice
dude and you know like you've done the
movies you've done you know did you
release a book
uh
we released uh a graphic novel like okay
yeah yeah i had a lot of fun making it
most people don't even know that existed
because they did not market it but right
i put my heart soul into a graphic novel
but no no actual book right that's
something
is that something you'd want to try or
is there like something else we just
like eventually i'd like to do it maybe
i i thought about putting together some
kind of like coffee table book
that
goes through the different interviews
i've done and talks about the different
things that i learned from each
interview the things that i've taken
from that and been able to apply to my
own life and the moments that stood out
to me
um
key things that i now go back to and
think about yeah so an autobiography
a little bit yeah hopefully it could be
also a way for people to
learn through me learning like that's
right that's part of why i do
the interview series i mean to be fair
if there's anyone who has enough
material to write a cohesive
autobiography
you know i i don't know if i feel like
putting it in the term of autobiography
i'm like
no
it's time
who have written autobiographies yeah
and you know and they're just like
i'm 24.
eight of them